welcome back president biden took steps  over the weekend to help border  officials process the  wave of unaccompanied minors showing up  recently at the southern border  cbs news has learned border patrol has 4  200 miners  in short-term holding facilities right  now that law requires them to be  transferred to more appropriate  facilities within  72 hours but many children have been  there far  longer than that lawyers say the centers  are overcrowded  and now lawmakers on capitol hill are  pointing fingers  the biden open border policies that are  inviting  even more illegal immigration what the  administration has inherited is a broken  system at the border and they are  working to correct that  the house is expected to debate two  immigration bills this week  one would protect dreamers undocumented  immigrants brought to the u.s  as children the other would provide  legal status for  farmworkers